I'm on my way to that health
retreat I was telling you about.
Apparently, I'm in need
of some fixing.
Masha:
Welcome to Tranquillum House.
We're gonna get you well.
Frances: This is gonna be
the best thing.
It has to be.
Masha:
Are you happy with your life?
Jessica:
We're not in a good place.
Either we try or....
we don't.
Delilah:
It's very intimate here.
Heather:
And how many guests are there?
Nine, total.
(cymbal rings)
I'm not sure I'm really
supposed to be here.
Some doors are meant
to stay closed.
Have you met her?
The woman that runs it?
She mixes and matches
her guests
like a cocktail.
Supposedly, she completely
changes people.
You came here to heal.
This is going to be
a wonderful journey.
Sometimes it'll be...
unpleasant.
I don't want to suffer.
You're already suffering.
Heather: I've been feeling
unlike myself.
There is nothing to fear.
You're mine now.
And you want to be mine.
♪ The end has just begun ♪